[Música]
las abejas son criaturas fascinantes por
varias razones por su ética de trabajo
increíble por el jarabe dulce azucarado
que producen y por su compleja
estructura social Pero otra razón es que
las abejas son de hecho excelentes
matemáticas
los científicos afirman que estos
insectos pueden calcular ángulos y
comprender la redondez de la tierra Pero
hay un Ingenio particular matemático
apícola detrás de lo más importante de
su vida La Colmena las abejas necesitan
alimentos y refugio para vivir La
Colmena no es solo el lugar de las
abejas sino que es donde guardan su miel
como es clave para su supervivencia
deben perfeccionar la arquitectura de La
Colmena
si examinamos un trozo de panal veremos
que está construido de celdas compactas
hexagonales de seis lados de todos los
diseños posibles porque eligieron este
las abejas para entenderlo hay que
pensar como abeja ellas necesitan un
lugar seguro para la colonia también es
necesario un lugar donde almacenar y
macerar el néctar hasta que se convierta
en miel
por eso necesitan gran eficiencia de
espacio
las soluciones construir celdas
suficientemente Grandes como para que
quepa una abeja que también puedan
funcionar como contenedores de néctar
los frascos de miel de las abejas
lo siguiente es decidir De qué están
hechas las celdas las abejas no tienen
picos ni brazos para recoger cosas pero
pueden producir cera pero producirla
lleva un arduo trabajo las abejas tienen
que consumir 240 gramos de miel para
producir 30 gramos de cera por eso no
quieren desperdiciarla
necesitan Un diseño para almacenar la
mayor cantidad de miel usando la menor
cantidad de cera
que forma lo permite supongamos que las
abejas fuesen a la Facultad de
arquitectura a clase de matemática y le
preguntaran al profesor de geometría qué
forma nos daría mayor espacio para
almacenar nuestra miel usando la menor
cantidad de cera el profesor de
geometría respondería la forma que
buscan es el círculo dejamos que las
abejas vuelvan a la construcción de
prueba a construir su Colmena de celdas
circulares
pasado un tiempo advertirán un problema
de diseño hay pequeñas rendijas entre
las celdas ni siquiera cabemos
desperdiciamos espacio podrían pensar
ignorando la lección de geometría y
tomando cartas en el asunto las abejas
vuelven al tablero de dibujo para
repensar el diseño de su Colmena una
sugiere triángulos podemos usar
triángulos miren encajan perfectamente
otras sugiere cuadrados interviene una
tercera y dice los pentágonos parecen no
funcionar pero los hexágonos sí queremos
la forma que use la menor cantidad de
cera y pueda almacenar la mayor cantidad
de miel sí es el hexágono porque es la
que más se parece a un círculo Cómo
comprobarlo para averiguarlo los
insectos arquitectos calcularon las
áreas del triángulo el cuadrado y el
hexágono y encontraron que el hexágono
era la forma que les daba más espacio de
almacenamiento estuvieron de acuerdo en
un tamaño ideal y volvieron a trabajar
La Colmena eficiente en espacio que es
Marca Registrada de una abeja hoy
probablemente sea resultado de esta
prueba y error pero en grandes periodos
de historia evolutiva
observen cualquier Colmena con gafas de
protección y máscara y verán el
resultado una Colmena compacta y hermosa
que sería el orgullo de cualquier
arquitecto
con este video viaje desde La Colmena
hasta la colina para seguir a una
hormiga colorada mientras construye una
colonia y elude a posibles usurpadoras
que compiten por su trono
[Música]